who are you
i mean really who are you
from an i.t perspective i don't mean in
an existential sense i just mean how
does your system know that you are who
you claim to be
in a previous video i talked about the
forays of identity and access management
and in this video i'm going to focus
specifically
on the second a authentication which is
answering that question who are you
the way we answer that question is based
upon a set of factors one factor might
be based upon something you know
another on something you have
another on something you are
so an example of something you know
might be a password or a pin
and the good thing about that is you can
generate it yourself you can change it
over time the problem with it is
it can be known and reside in more than
one brain at a time
as a result that means someone else
could potentially appear to be you from
the system's perspective if they know
your password so there are limits but
you can see what this is a very common
way of authenticating
another way of authenticating was
something you have and very commonly
these days people will do it with a
mobile phone
they'll pre-register that device with
the system and then a message gets sent
to that pre-registered device that only
you would be able to read if you possess
the phone
so that helps most people if you're like
me are not very far from their mobile
device
and if they lose it they're aware of it
and then they can report it
still some some limitations but there
are definitely definitely advantages to
this and then something you are now this
is something i never forget to take with
me as my face for instance now that's
not always good for everyone else but
it's good for me and i can use my face
as a biometric to unlock my phone and
when i do that that didn't require me to
remember any other things it's not
something that's easily replicatable if
the biometric is good
so these things we call factors of
authentication
these factors
then can be used as single factor
authentication or we can do what's known
as multi-factor authentication where i
take multiples of these at the same time
for instance i send a message to your
phone something you have
and you unlock the phone with your face
print something you are
now i've combined two factors into one
and now i have potentially something
that is stronger from a security
standpoint without all the complexity
and without some of the limitations of a
password if i were to use that so
ultimately i could use this as a way to
get down to
the the nirvana that a lot of people
want and that's a no password a
passwordless frictionless environment
that still preserves security
thanks for watching please remember to
like this video and subscribe to this
channel so we can continue to bring you
content that matters to you